the island of Cuba has been under the
Yoke of the Castro dictatorship for more
than 60 years a period of time in which
the island has become one of the poorest
countries in the Americas according to
available estimates the situation has
caused more than one million people to
leave the island over the last 25 years
and that's despite only having a total
population of just over 11 million
inhabitants it's like huge Exodus that
far from slowing down is gaining more
and more speed to give you an idea of
during the first nine months of 2022
alone it is estimated that nearly 200
000 Cubans escape from the island to the
United States a historical maximum that
surpasses any previous period so that is
the state of Cuba right now something we
will talk about at length here on
visualpolitik in the future
the fact is that in spite of this
complex situation in general the Castro
dictatorship has not had that much bad
press yes practically everybody accepts
that Cuba is a dictatorship but a
dictatorship with a certain name there
have always been myths that have
contributed to whitening the image of
castroism and in fact as Incredibles it
may seem Fidel Castro was one of the
most popular politicians in all of Latin
America during the 20th century and yes
we know Fidel had many detractors but
also many supporters and many stalwarts
one of the most effective communication
strategies of the Cuban regime has been
to regularly send hundreds and hundreds
thousands even of doctors to troubled
countries yes Cuban doctors have
certainly become very famous from Italy
to Jamaica to Venezuela passing through
all kinds of crises and disasters
throughout the world however did you
know that these medical missions
generate millions of dollars in income
for the regime well visual party viewers
in this video I'm going to tell you how
one of the best businesses generated by
Havana in the last 50 years came about
check this out
[Applause]
[Music]
over the years Cuban medicine has become
one of the great Legends of the Castro
regime I'm sure almost all of you have
heard this story that other people
punished by the Diabolical U.S blockade
who despite everything and overcoming
all adversaries has managed to build a
healthcare system at the Forefront of
the world too bad the real story is
quite different especially if you're an
average Cuban Jewel or Jose yes Cuba
does allocate a large chunk of its
resources to the medical system it is
estimated that approximately 11 of its
GDP supposedly this is allowed for
relatively good statistics in areas such
as average life expectancy and infant
mortality however there is a problem
this Oxford study you see on the screen
suggests that the statistics are
manipulated and that they are also
biased by their own economic situation
for example there were virtually no cars
and without cars there are no fatal Road
accidents what's more in Cuba there is
not a single Health Care System but two
different systems which coexist
[Music]
on the one hand there is the healthcare
system for both foreigners and the Cuban
Elite a system whose mission is to earn
foreign currency through medical tourism
of course as you can imagine this is the
Island's Cutting Edge system and it is
forbidden to ordinary Cubans they have
access to a very different Health Care
System where the infrastructure is
crumbling and supplies of all kinds are
lacking to give you an idea when a
patient has to go to one of these public
hospitals they have to bring their own
sheets towels food and soap the images
speak for themselves it is a very
different story from the one that is
usually paraded and the one that
explains a totally different reality
Cuba recognizes a severe shortage of
medicines for all types of diseases in
any case what is undeniable is that Cuba
has built such a good reputation that
Friends of the regime do not hesitate to
travel to the island for treatment of
any medical problem as you can see the
true creme de La Creme Evo Morales
anticipates his trip to Cuba to undergo
surgery
Chavez travels to Cuba to undergo a
special treatment the Venezuelan
Parliament authorizes the president to
be absent for an indefinite period of
time I don't know how to say thank you
to this this country said Florencia
kirschner on her farewell to Cuba the
daughter of Vice President Christina
Fernandez and the late former president
Nestor kirschner briefly described in
her Instagram account her stay and
treatment in the Caribbean country
before returning to Argentina where is
Daniel Ortega the Nicaraguan president's
long absence in the midst of the
coronavirus pandemic stimulates rumors
about his health Dora Mara Tellez who
was a member of Ortega's cabinet in the
1980s considers it very possible that he
is in Cuba in one way or another Cuban
Healthcare has become one of the
Island's great instruments of soft power
a huge loud healer for the revolution
I'm sure you all remember news items
like this one
[Music]
Cuba sends medical brigades to Italy and
Latin America to face the coronavirus
Cuban doctors go to Andorra their second
European destination against kovid 19.
Cuban doctors would stay in Mexico
longer than expected if cases of
covid-19 increase in September of 2005
Fidel Castro even ordered the creation
of an international contingent of
Physicians specializing in disasters and
major epidemics to assist the United
States and the aftermath of the
Hurricane Katrina in New Orleans this
group was called the Henry Ravi
International Medical Brigade later the
Brigade continued its work and was
commended by the World Health
Organization for its involvement in
Africa in containing the Ebola outbreak
and the question is what is really
behind all these missions is everything
as clean as it seems well in this video
we are going to discover what is behind
all of these operations this visual
politic viewers is the flip side of
Cuba's best diplomatic tool check this
out
Health diplomacy and revolutionary
solidarity
in 1963 the Sans War took place a war
between Algeria and Morocco where Cuba
intervened in a geopolitical context in
which the island nation used to take
part in various Wars in favor of the
sides aligned with the Soviet Union of
course on this occasion something very
particular happened the lack of doctors
in the area made Fidel Castro come up
with the strategy of sending brigades of
health professionals to cover the
shortage and assist the soldiers and the
victims of the conflict it was the dress
rehearsal of a policy that became
increasingly massive common and
systematic although here's a little
aside it may surprise you but between
1960 and 1990 the Cuban Armed Forces
carried out at least eight military
interventions in the world five of them
in Africa Algeria Syria Congo Angola and
Ethiopia and the rest were in Central
America and the Caribbean let's just say
that during the Soviet era the Cuban
Army became an expeditionary troop at
the service of the Communist Revolution
however the increasing failure of these
Expeditions began to boost Castro to
conceive of a different way of
influencing third countries perhaps a
friendlier way and that is how after the
Algerian experience the Curious strategy
of the medical brigades began to appear
since that first trial in 1963 according
to figures promoted by the regime itself
some 600 000 Cuban healthcare workers
have provided medical services and more
than 160 countries and take note because
there are currently some 30 000 Cuban
doctors who seem to be active and
deployed in 67 countries we are talking
about a well-oiled system of soft power
both logistically and economically
especially when we consider that Cuba
has turned this activity into a huge
business and yes you heard correctly a
huge and lucrative business check this
out
[Music]
a very profitable business for the
regime
[Music]
personally a hermetic country and
everything that involves the government
that's the thing about dictatorships
they're not exactly the most transparent
places however in spite of all this
since the year 2000 certain methods and
rules regarding the Recruitment and
financing of medical programs around the
world have become known which to tell
the truth did not set well with the most
basic rights of any worker and somewhat
later in March 2010 the Cuban government
issued resolution number 168 which
establishes the disciplinary regulations
for Cuban civilian workers serving
abroad as collaborators check this out
[Music]
the document has been very controversial
since its release among other reasons
because of the infractions it
establishes regarding the discipline
related to The Prestige and social
conduct of employees for example this
regulation sanctions behaviors such as
those you see on the screen article 8G
to maintain relations with Nationals or
foreigners whose conduct is not in
accordance with the principles and
values of society article 8j to maintain
friendly relations or ties of any other
kind with Cuban citizens whether or not
there is Aid in the country where the
collaboration is provided and who
constitute promoters of a way of life
contrary to the principles that should
be characterized a Cuban collaborator
abroad and article 8 p not to inform
superiors of gifts received from
Nationals or foreigners that is to say
no fraternization with non-revolutionary
and non-communist people and of course
no relations even a friendship that are
not notified and approved by their
superiors
[Music]
and these are just three examples of a
long long list of disciplinary
regulations that regulate every aspect
of the life of medical workers abroad
and of course all Cuban doctors are
subject to the penal code in the event
they allow themselves to be tempted by
the capitalist Comforts that many find
in the countries where they render their
services the public official or employee
in charge of fulfilling a mission in
another country who abandons it or
having fulfilled it or having been
requested at any time to return
expressly or tacitly refuses to do so
incurs the penalty of deprivation of
Liberty from three to eight years
article 176.1 of the Cuban penal code in
view of this I don't know it doesn't
seem that such a strict code with
extensive control over the lives of
workers fits well with the image of
volunteering doctors coming to provide
altruistic help and the question is will
there be a backlash
well the truth is that in 2009 the
United Nations special Rapport tours on
trafficking and persons of contemporary
forms of slavery dedicated part of their
work to Cuba and the economic circuit
designed to raise millions of dollars
from these missions which were no longer
viewed as so humanitarian among other
things the rap War cheers asked the
Cuban government to explain this
information and take action
the government of Cuba would receive a
sum of money from the host governments
and pay the workers a portion of those
funds in countries where the host
government pays the Cuban worker
directly the Cuban worker must pay back
to the government of Cuba a percentage
of his or her salary which would
increase from 75 to up to 90 percent of
his or her monthly salary un special
rapporteur on contemporary forms of
slavery 2019. that is not only can they
not have unapproved relationships
refused to work or seek to settle in
another country but Cuban health workers
are also not paid in a manner consistent
with the work they're doing
[Music]
according to a report by prisoners
Defenders of the U.S 10 700 for three
months approximately three thousand five
hundred and sixty dollars per month but
the Mexican Government paid for each of
the 585 Cuban doctors and nurses serving
in the country's capital Havana only
gave them six hundred dollars for three
months 200 a month as a fixed charge in
the country in other words the Cuban
government kept 94.4 percent of the
amount it's charged for his doctors and
gave them a pittance on which it is not
even possible to have a decent standard
of living in Mexico
but that's not all the UN officials also
asked for clarification on the working
hours and schedules that the health
workers are forced to work the doctors
would work 48 hours per week plus an
additional 16 hours on call which
increases to a total of 64 hours per
week often including Saturdays and
Sundays the excess of hours worked
illustrates the labor exploitation to
which Cuban doctors abroad would be
subjected un special rapporteur on
contemporary forms of slavery 2019. all
of the service of the Revolution or
rather of the revolution's top brass
and these conditions were precisely the
ones that made the European Parliament
itself condemn the Cuban medical mission
system in June 2021 for the first time a
major political institution clearly
pointed out the real nature of the Cuban
missions the European Parliament
condemns the systemic violations of
humor and labor rights committed by the
Cuban State against its health personnel
sent to serve abroad on medical missions
European Parliament resolution of 10th
June 2021 on human rights and the
political situation in Cuba but wait a
minute because Beyond labor exploitation
and diplomatic influence in soft power
Cuba's Health missions may have another
much more dodgy objective no less than
directly exporting the revolution check
this out
Beyond appearances
Venezuela has probably been the country
where Cuban medical missions have
intervened the most in fact Hugo Chavez
himself made the issue one of his
campaign actors in the 2012 presidential
elections
venezolano
pero Canada
it is known that the regime maintained
and maintains a close collaboration with
Cuba and that also in exchange for Cuban
doctors Venezuela delivered oil to the
Cuban regime but that is not all it is
suspected and there are quite clear
indications that these brigades in many
cases also act as a kind of Trojan Horse
thanks to them and is part of the
Medical Teams many members of Cuban
intelligence were deployed in Venezuela
to infiltrate all levels and layers of
the Venezuelan society and support the
Chavez regime
that is why when the Mexican Government
of Andres Manuel Lopez obrador recently
announced a similar though much smaller
program of Cuban doctors alarms were
raised about the consequences this could
have about the risk that the Cuban
intelligence might try to take advantage
of these missions to do the same thing I
had done in Venezuela to try and control
the country and saw the flame of the
Revolution or at least use the network
to develop and exploit illegal
businesses to gain influence and foreign
currency given that in this case the
deployment is very small the real risk
seems very limited but what can I say
having queuing intelligence Services
operating openly in a country does not
seem like the best idea in the world
well this is the flip side of the Cuban
medical missions these missions do not
only exploit thousands of health workers
as if they were slave labor but the
regime uses them as an instrument of
white power and even as a mechanism to
infiltrate other countries so the next
thing you see any news about these
agreements pay attention because this is
one of the most important strategies of
influence and foreign currency
generation for one of the most
influential dictatorships of recent
decades because as you know in
international politics what seems honest
can hide a terrible reality I have
having said that it's over to you did
you know this modus operandi of Cuba
around the world what do you think of
this type of strategy levers your
impressions in the comments and let's
open a respectful debate and if you
found this video interesting don't
forget to like And subscribe to all of
us here on visualpolitik if you haven't
already done so thanks very much and
I'll see you next time
[Music]